[Music]  [Music]  but her daughter is gone  suffocating with 38 others in the back  of the lorry  she sent a final message home  dreaming of a better life 26 year old me  paid her smugglers more than  16 000 pounds to bring her to the uk  she was dead before she arrived  when he  his wife is too devastated  sorrow echoes across this poor pocket of  north central vietnam where most of the  victims lived  lana nai's 18 year old son teep is  also among the dead  like many they borrowed huge amounts of  money to pay for his trip  unaware of the danger  we were assured they'd go in a  four-seater car his mother says  instead teep was dehumanized  transported like cargo till the air ran  out  dreams crushed futures stolen  children dead there is no soothing the  wounds  left by the traffickers greed  siobhan robbins sky news